we have decided that the following
restrictions will be introduced from
this sunday until the 30th of january
all restaurants and bars excluding
takeaways or delivery services must
close at 8pm
there should be no indoor events after 8
pm
for indoor events scheduled earlier in
the day
attendance should be limited to 50
percent of venue capacity or 1 000
people whichever is lower
attendance at all outdoor events should
be limited to 50 of venue capacity or 5
000 people whichever is lower
wedding receptions can take place after
8 pm but with a capacity limit of 100
guests
restricted movement advice for all close
contacts will be enhanced
for those who have received a booster at
least one week ago
they would have to restrict movement for
five days and take three antigen tests
for those that have not yet received a
booster then booster they must restrict
their movement for ten days the hsc will
consider the best testing regime for
people in this category
all people arriving into the country
from overseas will be required to have
an antigen or pcr test in line with
their vaccination or recovery status
and all passengers arriving in ireland
should now be advised to conduct antigen
testing on a daily basis for a period of
five consecutive days commencing on the
day of arrival
none of this is easy
we are all exhausted with covet
and the restrictions it requires
the twists and turns the disappointments
and the frustrations take a heavy toll
on everyone
but it is the reality that we are
dealing with
we cannot wish it away
and there is no silver bullet to fix it
we talk about living with covid
and some believe that this means just
going back to how we did things before
it arrived
it doesn't
it means understanding the disease
monitoring it
making changes when it changes
and doing whatever we need to to protect
people's lives health and livelihoods
the news this evening will be deeply
disappointing for many
it is not the news i wanted to bring you
nor is it the news you wanted to hear
however
and this is important
the truth is that we are in a much
better place than we were this time last
year
and we will be in a much better place in
2022
the new year will bring new anti-viral
drugs and new therapeutics
our economic recovery has been much
stronger than anyone predicted and this
will endure next year
we just need to get to the other side of
this omicron wave as safely as possible
as we have done throughout this covert
crisis
we just need to remember that each of us
is responsible for all of us
we will come through this latest setback
as we have come through everything else
that covert has thrown at us together
we may have to dig a little bit deeper
to access it this time
but the unique resilience solidarity
and trust in science that has marked
ireland out across the world will get us
through this too
this christmas please please be safe
and look after each other
go
glare